hello everybody today is my birthday yes
yeah I'm 23 today and I suppose that's
cause for some celebration but I also
wanted to take a moment to you know
thank you guys as I usually do I don't
thank you guys enough I don't get it
you know even though I thank you every
the end of every single video that's
still not enough because you guys are
done a tremendous job of getting my new
channel back on its feet
let me give you some more statistics
just so you have an idea um the view
count has been slow but as of this video
I have one thousand seven hundred
seventy five subscribers I have ten
thousand nine hundred and twenty-eight
likes thirty-seven dislikes that's sad
but you know in proportion that's that's
a pretty amazing difference so generally
like 2309 favorites 1862 comments and
abysmally low 56 shares
I guess you're into different mechanic
but God but sad that that's so low but
that's okay and because it is my
birthday and I get a birthday wish my
one wish would be that I have more
people that enjoy my videos so I have a
job for you guys if you're interested in
doing it go find a friend tie them to a
chair bound and gag them roll them up to
your computer and play all my videos to
them no I'm just joking but what I would
like you know I've made it basically a
decision that I want to be a big
youtuber someday and that may take a
year to do but it's something that I
want so if you guys can help me out and
everyone who watches a video give me one
more subscriber that would be fantastic
just go out and find someone make them
subscribe time to a chair sign them up
to YouTube you know do everything again
I'm just joking that's fine you don't
have to do that but thank you again
everybody for watching and liking my
videos I couldn't do this without you
and I'm not going to be able to go into
the future without you so it's all on
you you're gonna help me out get big so
thanks again everybody oh and um right
now if you're watching this future
you're gonna miss it but right now drunk
minecraft right here click on that
button it might happen unless my family
wants to do something for my birthday
because they're coming over today but
anyway if there's a link up there
like it to go to my livestream channel
and if you didn't know I do live streams
on twitch TV so if you want to see me
live and in action playing some video
games go ahead and give me a check out
or go ahead and check me out
um go over and if you haven't already
click on the link go over there and
follow me or favorite or whatever you
want to call it whatever it's called on
twitch TV so that you can always stay up
to date
whenever I'm live-streaming so thanks
again everybody thank you everybody for
watching and I will see you in the next
video bye bye